George Santos may be one of the biggest
Liars in the 2024 uh 2023 uh Republic
did I say 2025 I'm now thinking I might
have earlier in the show said it was
2024. did I do that I don't know why I
just had a flashback
2023 Congress that is now uh taking
power George Santos had a really wacky
wacky day yesterday uh on Capitol Hill
as a reminder George Santos is the
Republican elect uh Congressman elect
becoming Congressman now presumably from
representing New York who lied about his
employment history he lied about his
educational history he lied about his uh
Jewish background which seems to be
imaginary he's under uh U.S criminal
investigation Brazil is criminally
investigating him
etc etc
he had quite a day in Washington DC
you've got to see this stuff first in an
effort to avoid having to talk to any
media he just kind of did this thing
where he walks quickly and tries to get
away from reporters he ended up walking
into the dead end of a basement hallway
in the Longworth House Office Building
while trying to get away from reporters
you've got to see this stuff
Santos do you tend to serve both years
of your term
not taking any questions by the way tell
us if you plan to serve both here's your
term Mr Santos
will you answer any question besides
will you support leader McCarthy to be
speaker
concerns about your biography
told folks about your background oh my
God
probably the leadership told you
anything Mr Santos
explain about your biography your resume
all right so hitting a dead end there
and having to turn around and then it
gets even more Awkward
um uh laylee ibsa tried asking him some
questions when he first showed up
yesterday he also didn't want to answer
those your constituents
do you feel like you're qualified to
serve in this Congress right now
by the way the backpack I know
I know biography to them
what's your response to calls for a
house after investigation
do you have any statements about your
campaign and how you hope to govern
no
the mirror I I love the question this
guy's not going to govern are you nuts
that it's a funny question in that he's
obviously not going to do any governing
hope to carry out your full term
what can you say to reassure your
constituents so you'll do what you said
you're going to do on your campaign
all right you get the point walking
miles seemingly avoiding questions from
reporters I don't know how tenable it's
going to be for him to just never answer
questions then we get to him sitting in
the house chamber and you almost start
to feel bad for him except that you
don't
um as proceedings were going on just
sitting by himself on his phone and we
have video of it um right now that we're
showing you sitting uh by himself
looking dejected sulking in the house
chamber
um on his phone and just nobody talking
to him you let me know whether you feel
bad I mean listen he he lied about
everything you know this guy really
really did lie about everything and now
I mean listen it's not like Republicans
are honest it's not like I have a
delusion that the reason Republicans are
shunning him is because they're honest
and this guy is dishonest obviously
that's not the case uh but it is just
funny and kind of like weird to see
um there he is picking his nose and
we'll actually look at that moment a
little more closely that was a much
scrutinized moment almost like the
Zapruder film uh you will see here that
he does an interesting move as he sits
there where he goes in for the pick
and then very casually does a sort of
rolling motion does a kind of a rolling
motion and he does seem to be able to
dislodge the mucus that he was able to
obtain there and then lastly when this
was all said and done George Santos
attempting to leave the capital again
sort of disoriented and not taking any
questions from Caitlin way burns from
CBS News can you tell us how your first
day was
Congressman Santos
he really does look like a lost kid on
the first day of camp with the backpack
and everything and just it's it's
bizarre imagery
it's like how the hell do I get out of
here
can you tell us how your first day was
no
well nobody talked to me and the kids
were mean do you have anything to say
about all of the allegations
against you
are you confident that you'll be sworn
in yes
and off he goes into the Dark Knight
ultimately finding an elevator that
would eventually take him outside this
doesn't seem at all sustainable and one
would imagine at some point if George
Santos is actually going to serve he's
going to have to answer questions from
someone and they're gonna have to be
real questions not like those softball
interviews that we looked at last week
so a tough first day at school at work
sorry for George Santos unclear whether
he had those Capri Sun juice pouches in
his backpack or what but not going well
and we will see what happens today
nothing definitive by the way
as to whether there was any kind of quid
pro quo between Santos and Kevin
McCarthy the of course speculated quid
pro quo would be McCarthy supports
Santos not resigning and being sworn in
Santos pledges to vote for McCarthy for
speaker of the house and all day amidst
all those questions the one thing that
McCarthy uh rather that Santos did
answer is that yes he will be supporting
Kevin McCarthy for speaker if you've
just been listening today and you're
curious about the visual component for
these things that I've played check them
out on our Instagram which you can find
at davidpackman show and of course we'll
also have all of these clips on our
YouTube channel make sure you were
subscribed to the big very big YouTube
channel youtube.com the David Pacman
show there is something you use at home
every day that is significantly harming
the planet and it is your toilet paper
30 million and trees are destroyed every
year for toilet paper in the U.S alone
deforestation is a contributor to
climate change and I think moving away
from tree based toilet paper is
something we can all do and that's why I
asked real paper to be our sponsor real
paper is a toilet paper made 100 from
bamboo stocks which grow forever so no
cutting down trees and all of real
papers packaging is plastic free think
of all those big plastic bags you've
thrown out over the years real paper is
a b Corp certified by the forest
Stewardship Council and real paper
plants one tree with every purchase you
make and the best part is you can do a
part to fight climate change without
making any sacrifice because real paper
is soft and fluffy and durable just like
traditional toilet paper you're used to
guys this is a no-brainer for anyone who
cares about about the issue of
deforestation give real paper a try go
to realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 30 off your first order plus
free shipping the link is down below